CBS News has new information about a
possible chemical weapons attack that
may be planned by Syrian President
Bashar al-assad
the White House last night issued an
extraordinary warning to the Syrian
leader it says he will pay quote a heavy
price if he launches another chemical
attack a US official says intelligence
detected activity near the same Syrian
chemical weapons bunker connected to
that deadly attack back in April more
than 80 people including children were
killed in response the u.s. fired 59
cruise missiles at a Syrian government
airbase Margaret Brennan is at the White
House with more on this story Margaret
good morning good morning while this
ominous White House statement was issued
late last night after US intelligence
detected activity around sharat airfield
now that is the same location from which
that deadly April chemical weapons
attack was launched now according to
what a US official tells our own CBS
News is David Martin there is activity
around that same chemical weapons bunker
which was not destroyed during the US
strike due to fear at the time that it
would spread the toxic material the US
has also picked up increased
communications by the Syrian unit
responsible for chemical weapons however
it is not clear whether that is
preparation for an attack or simply
movement for another reason
such as an inspection US diplomats tell
me that they were caught off guard by
the strong language that was used in
this White House statement however this
did come just hours after a intense
phone call between Russia's top diplomat
and Secretary of State Rex Tillerson
that extraordinary warning came
following the call during which Russia
did confirm that preventing future
chemical weapons attacks was a
conversation point Lavrov also said he
was very frustrated at three recent US
military strikes against militias who
are backing the Assad regime now Nora we
do know that later this morning
president Trump has plans to speak with
France's leader and men well Matt cron
and I am hearing from European diplomats
that they are seeing very similar
intelligence
King what we just told you US
intelligence officials have seen and
they will be discussing this on the call
with Trump military activity and options
have been a point of conversation in
France as well alright great reporting
Margaret Brennan at the White House
thank you